bitte Karrueche joins us columnist
writer for the Buffalo News also hosts
Sirius XM NFL radio good morning Vick
how's morale in Buffalo good man good
morning again not so good not so good
all right take me when did you realise
Vontae Davis had decided to quit slash
retire well it's interesting because you
know we're sitting in the press box and
you of course you try to pay attention
to all that you can see not just inside
the white lines but using binoculars
watching the sidelines and at one point
one of my colleagues said you see Lonny
Davis anywhere and I'm looking this is
the third quarter looks like yeah you
know I don't see you number 22 where
where is he we're and we're kind of
going up but then of course you assume
an injury and then you check with PR and
and you're getting no response there so
something was up and and and no the last
thing anyone thought for even a second
is that he yeah took his uniform off put
the street clothes on and head of that
Orchard Park for good what did his
teammate say they were a little upset
Dan just to say the least it was it was
an angry bunch I mean look you're on the
wrong end of a 31 to 20 game it's
another embarrassing performance and
this defense of course has become really
the focal point of this oh and to start
because it was expected to be better and
he was expected to be a part of this he
started the game I mean he was he was
the starter opposite Trudeau vyas white
and his teammates were mad Lorenzo white
35 year old you know veteran Kyle
Williams they were angry why Lorenzo
Alexander excuse me said it couldn't
remember a time in in any level of
football where this happened Kyle
Williams used this phrase he said he's
where he needs to be and then a reporter
filled in meaning not here and Kyle says
exactly okay aside from this you know
Josh Allen how would you assess John
Jones performance I thought it was
encouraging I think that's the right
word he definitely did some rookie
things and the two interceptions he
threw I think we're both avoidable as he
talked about
lays one where he's in the process of
being sacked and really what he should
have done was either taking the Sacre
throwing the ball away but he couldn't
help himself he's trying to to make
something happen so he throws the heaves
desperation ball in the end of direction
of Marcus Murphy that gets picked off
but and there were like overall 5 secs
that he took and i would say i'm three
of them dan he probably was was not
decisive enough with what to do and and
so the charger defense with a lot of
different mixing up upfronts and
coverages did exactly what you should do
against a rookie but the encouraging
thing is he he has the ability to make
some some rare throws that i think that
the rare talent in his arm allows him to
do and that will get better can run and
and run effectively when when it's
needed but i think more more than
anything listening to his teammates they
love the command that he showed in the
huddle and they love the attitude the
approach the the kid once he found out
on wednesday that he's the guy you know
he did the cliche first guy in last guy
out that that seemed real based on what
his teammate said is this managerial
tanking I know the players are trying to
win but did it just feels like Buffalo
is farther and farther away from being a
playoff Tim yeah it makes you wonder
where it's going now we the the
presumption going into this year was
even though it was a playoff season last
year they would likely take a backward
step before they started going forward
just because you rebuilt so much of this
roster you had three spots you filled on
the offensive line I had to replace on
the line alone and you didn't expect the
Eric wood retirement and the Richie
incognito blow up all of that so those
were maybe some unanticipated things but
that all said they they've changed over
a lot of this roster and you need to
assume it's going to take a step back I
just didn't think though it would look
this far back in only two games and when
when the Vontae Davis thing by you know
by Wednesday we're going to really kind
of move on and forget about that what
lingered in though I think is the
judgment in bringing this guy in this
was this guy was brought in as a starter
right Mel bollard and in so for to get a
guy like that who walks out on you all
walks out on teammates I think it's
gonna make a lot of other players
scratch their heads yeah just trying to
figure out what to expect out of Buffalo
and I don't expect much but you know now
I'm looking at if I'm a Browns fan I
feel a whole lot better after looking at
Buffalo and who would have thought that
going into the season Jake know you
you're absolutely right those are the my
thoughts exactly that in that in you
know in a in a 0 1 1 start for the
Browns they they look more competitive
they look more engaged than than the own
two bills no no question
good stuff Vic I'm sure it'll be
interesting in Orchard Park here in the
next couple of days but thanks for
joining us my pleasure Dan anytime
that's Vic Karrueche
he said Bill's writer Buffalo News
Sirius XM NFL radio host as well yeah I
know Vontae Davis will get a little and
got more attention than he probably
deserved it's just rare that a guy quits
at halftime and and that's it I mean
that's just legacy you spent 10 years to
try to build a legacy and now when
somebody goes oh are you gonna Vontae
Davis I'm like he's gonna write are you
gonna Vontae Davis me are you gonna
Vontae Davis the team for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]